hey what's up guys welcome back
now in a previous video I showed you how we can
take those little party poppers and
convert them into an extremely powerful
confetti cartridge these are basically
just water bottles charged with hydroxy
gas packed tight with colored dots
punched out of construction paper and
held in place with fire resistant party
streamers I got from the dollar store
if we try touching an open flame to the
stream or you can see it really doesn't
burn and that's good because we're going
to have a live match going off inside of
there you can see that no matter what
direction the bottle is in for the most
part the confetti stays near the top and
that's what we want now for this video I
thought it'd be fun to make a trip wire
trigger board for setting these things
off remotely or safely from a distance
this is the basic idea of how our trip
wire trigger board is going to work
simply remove the safety switch position
the trigger any direction you want
when this switch gets tripped that's when all
the fun begin it's quite a bit easier to
make that it look so let's dive right in
and I'll show you how
for our booby trap
mounting board I went to the hardware
store and found a scrap piece of pine
common board and cut it so it's eight
inches long and five inches tall now if
you want to get fancy just throw it on
your wood router and route the edges
that give it a really clean and
professional look and if you want to go
the extra mile you can even give it a
camouflage paint job that just makes it
look really clean and professional
wherever you put it now for
functionality I'm going to start off
with our lantern battery I'm going to
place it right in the center of the
board here but before we secure this in
place it's a good idea to take our
trigger mechanism and make sure that
there's enough clearance to clear that
lantern battery because this will give
us the option to place it down up or
even sideways depending on what setting
and what you were going to use it for
aside from that we're bringing back the
hydrogen generator to split water into
hydrogen oxygen gas filling up a water
bottle and mounting all these components
to this board let's go ahead and put it
all together now
now you're going to need some kind of an
insulated copper cord I just went down
to the thrift store and bought a
cell phone charger for about a dollar cut the
head off split it down the center
and just like that we've got two insulated
copper wires that would be perfect for this project
okay that looks preety awesome using one of the bottle caps I'm
going to rig up a system that allow us
to easily swap out igniters so this
system we're reusable and you won't have
to keep hot gluing igniters and every
time you use it the way to do that is to
poke a small hole through the cap run
both wires and then hot glue it from
both sides and we're going to hot glue
the wires as well so they keep a little
bit of a distance from each other and
they don't accidentally short out inside
the bottle I'm also going to be using
some of these homemade igniters we made
it in one of our rocket projects that
use the match and one thin wire tonight
with electricity and all triggered by
one of these clothes pin tripwire
mechanisms that will show you how to
make another future project
so theoretically this is how the system is
going to work we've got a six volt
lantern battery that can set off a match
by itself but we've rigged it up with
the circuitry so that our two broken
circuits as long as the circuit is open
there's no way that match can light but
once we close that the only switch left
waiting to be activated is the
clothespin when the centerpiece gets
pulled out these electrical contacts
will slam shut shooting electricity
through the igniter which will flare up
light off the gas and make a
surprisingly powerful explosion which
will make a huge mess that somebody's
going to have to clean up now if you've
ever used a firearm you know there's a
safety feature that will block you from
pulling the trigger prematurely in the
same respect I've added a safety feature
to this where a pin has to be pulled out
first before you can actually initiate
the trip wire from here all we have to
do is remove the cap insert the igniter
set it in the system and it's pretty
much charged and ready to go at that
point
so now that we've got this beautiful
contraption built there's a lot of
different ways that we can integrate in
fact the imagination is probably your
only limitation you could use it
anywhere one of these worked up in a
break room works great for pranking one
of your fellow employees ring this
contraption through the microwave hide
it in the wastebasket and when they go
to grab their lunch they're going to be
in for a majors
another idea is to mount
this contraption on the doorframe in the
bathroom or some other room that doesn't
get used very often use something like
double sided sticky tape to stick it to
the wall rig the fishing line to the
back of the door and very carefully set
the trigger the next time someone walks
through that door unsuspectingly they're
probably gonna end up making a huge mess of their own
guys its important to
remember this is actually a really
really dangerous project these are not
the kind of pranks you want to play on
your coworkers these are more of the
kind of jump scare prank you'd play on
me but this concept could easily be
adapted to make a trip wire alarm an
airsoft grenade you could use this
system to light fireworks safely from a
distance or even make a zombie perimeter
breach so you get a heads up on when
they're coming so there you have it guys
that's how to make a booby-trapped
tripwire trigger board
stay safe and
I'll see you in the next project video
talk to you then.
BOOM!
I forgot my earplugs (Guy in background: I did too) .dang it hahaha that hurt a lot